This 3D printer has the ability to print fruit.
And a laser device can detect the presence
of alcohol vapors in passing cars then send
a photo to police officers waiting down the
road.
Vsauce! Kevin Here.... this is Mind Blow.
Supernumerary robotic limbs will give you
extra arms. Researchers at MIT are designing
them to help with tasks that may be otherwise
impossible such as screwing in objects over
head or opening a door while having your hands
full. They're also working on prototypes that
can be worn around the waist and on making
the arms intuitive to movements to predict
what the wearer needs help with.
Keplar 10c is a rocky mega Earth that weighs
17 times more than our planet and this new
discovery means potentially habitable planets
could be closer than we thought.
SynTouch gives prosthetic hands the ability
to mimic human fingertips. The tactile sensors
can distinguish between different objects
and surface textures and the hand can also
sense the pressure needed to pick up an object
without crushing or damaging it. The fingertips
consist of a rigid core surrounded by an elastic
liquid-filled skin.
The Infinadeck is an omnidirectional treadmill
designed to work in virtual realities. The
user can walk in any direction infinitely
and they're hoping to use this for applications
ranging from gaming and law enforcement training
to physical fitness.
Researchers at MIT are creating a camouflage
generator that could eventually lead to digital
invisibility cloaks. The algorithm analyzes
multiple photos of a scene taken from different
angles and makes a camouflage image to cover
eyesores like electrical boxes, air conditioners,
or portable toilets. But they still have a
ways to go in order to account for changes
in lighting.
The CityHome can make a 200 square foot home
feel three times bigger. The transformable
gesture-controlled multipurpose unit can become
a bed, a desk, and a dining table. And can
be easily moved doubling the size of your
living room, bathroom or kitchen. But no word
yet on when this will be available to the
public.
This newly discovered fish dwells in cave
streams in Southern Indiana and has no eyes
but does have an anus behind its head.
Researchers at Rice University have developed
a method of killing or damaging cancer cells
by using gold nanoparticles. After the use
of some chemotherapy the gold nanoparticles
that target specific cancer cells are introduced.
They're stored just beneath the protective
outer membrane of the cancer cell when a tiny
laser is shone on the cells. Since the gold
can't absorb that wavelength of light it creates
tiny bubbles that explode and destroy the
cancer cell.
Betabrand has created a reflective button
down shirt that makes it easier for bicyclists
and pedestrians to be seen by motorists. Reflective
yarns are woven into the design and the idea
is to create fashionable clothing that can
be worn during the day but safe at night.
New York City is preparing for a massive storm
by creating an 8 mile long stretch of dikes
and a 16 foot high barrier that will have
varying functions for the city during non
storm times. Including aquariums, parks, and
public art space. And a total of $920 million
dollars was recently awarded for various storm
proofing efforts.
This robot from Korea can run 46 kilometers
per hour and was inspired by velociraptors...
so yeah.
The Genneo is a portable generator that captures
energy from your movements and converts it
into power for your electronic devices. Every
five hours of just carrying the Genneo provides
an hour of talk time and shaking the device
multiplies the rate of charging by 20. They
can be pre charged before you leave and are
kept charged by your movements.
Finally Octopuses of the Night is an underwater
film shot by Dustin Adamson during his night
dives in
the Philippines.
I'm going to leave you with pizza making robots...
and as always... thanks for watching.